[Musique]
naya emménagent dans son nouveau condo
son déménagement est simple car elle n'a
pas de gros appareils à transporter en
effet l'ancien propriétaire lui a vendu
ses électroménager elle les avait elle
même acheté trois mois plus tôt alors
qu'elle ne pensait pas vendre la maison
quelques semaines plus tard ça va mal la
sécheuse refuse de fonctionner et naya à
une tonne de vêtements à faire sécher
pourtant la sécheuse et presque neuve
elle a été achetée il ya moins d'un an
par l'ancien propriétaire alors la
garantie d'un an tu fabriques à l'hôtel
pour naya non à cause de cette clause
dans la garantie
adieu la garantie du fabricant pour naya
il lui reste quand même des recours
contre celle qui lui a vendu la sécheuse
ou en vertu de la garantie légale contre
le commerçant ou le fabricant le fin mot
de l'histoire
vous achetez un bien presque neuf de
particuliers et vous tenez à la garantie
du fabricant demander d'abord le
document de la garantie et assurez vous
qu'elle est transférable